monsieur le président de la Mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduitesictives la 1 des
cas nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ici on va vous demander de
présenter les personnes qui vous
accompagnent et puis avant de répondre
aux questions de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'impact du narcotrafic en
France et les mesures à prendre bouill
remédier nous allons nous
euh conformer à cette obligation de
prestation de servment qui est
obligatoire devant une commission
d'enquête euh donc je vous laisse vous
présenter puis je ferai procéder à la
prestation de servment après monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur merci
beaucoup à mon tour de de de vous
remercier pardon pour nous recevoir donc
je suis Nicolas prise je suis médecin de
santé publique président de la Mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives je
suis accompagné de Valérie saintoyant
qui est délégué de Laam DESC du
commissaire divisionnaire CIA Bobet
chargé de mission police au sein de la
même
institution alors je rappelle qu'un faut
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévu aux articles 434-13 434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal et donc je vous
invite chacune et chacun d'entre vous
qui allit prendre la parole à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure je jure je jure je
cure merci
beaucoup ce que je vous propose
peut-être dans le droitfil du
questionnaire qui vous a été transmis
c'est peut-être qu'on vous laisse une
intervention liminaire la durée que vous
souhaitez on se donne une heure maximum
puisqu'on enchaîne les auditions et puis
après on passera à l'exercice des
questions
réponses parfait merci et puis Étienne
blanc veillera au bon ordonnancement de
tout ce
travail merci beaucoup comme vous m'y
invitez donc un propos liinaire que
j'espère tenir en une dizaine de minutes
10 15 minutes si ça vous va peut-être
pour vous rappeler d'abord qu'est-ce que
fait la mission interministérielle de
lutte contre les drogues et les
conduites addictives qui est donc une
institution une administration
interministérielle comme son nom
l'indique placé auprès du premier
ministre et de la première ministre en
l'occurrence depuis 2008 qui a été créé
en fait en
1982 sous une autre appellation
naturellement peut-être se rappeler que
notre travail consiste à nous occuper si
j'ose dire des d'abord licite le tabac
et l'alcool qui sont les grands
pourvoyeurs de mortalité de coût social
en France mais bien entendu ce qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
produits stupéfiants ainsi qu'un certain
nombre de conduites addictives
ou addiction constitué qui ne se basent
pas sur des produits mais qui ont trait
à des comportement tel que l'usage
excessif des écrans le jeux vidéo les
jeux de hasard et d'argent voilà ce
qu'on essaie d'embrasser avec une double
perspective limiter le niveau des
consommations en France et limiter la
fréquence et la gravité
de leurs complications y compris pour la
société au-delà des complications de
nature individuelle notre travail
interministériel est un travail de
coordination de l'action publique en
mobilisant l'ensemble des leviers de
l'action publique en facilitant leur
articulation des sujets les plus
régaliens encore une fois ceux qui nous
occupent aujourd'hui jusqu'à
l'accompagnement des personnes la
réduction des risques et des dommages
avec un vaste ensemble de politiques
publi qui concerne la prévention au sens
très large du terme qui ne concerne pas
que le ministère de la Santé avec une
prévention éducative en particulier dont
nous pourrons reparler si vous le
souhaitez cette coordination vise à
mettre en cohérence l'action publique
favoriser les articulations les
innovations et finalement dépasser
totalement cette dualité qui pour nous
est inopérante entre la répression d'un
côté la prévention de l'autre il y a
matière à travailler sur les deux
aspects à travailler également sur
l'accompagnement et la réduction des
risques alors on soutient
méthodologiquement un certain nombre
d'acteurs je vous en énumérerai
quelquesuns on soutient financièrement
certains de ces acteurs au niveau
national comme au niveau local on essaie
de repérer des manques des angles morts
dans la politique publique c'est comme
ça que là encore une fois on en
reparlera mais qu'on a identifié un
angle qui était la prévention de la
participation des jeunes au trafic de
stupéfiants comment est-ce qu'on peut
essayer d'agir en prévention j'allais
dire primaire de C de ces dérives là on
essaie aussi de repérer des bonnes
pratiques qui existent ici ou là et de
faire émerger encore une fois pour
dépasser cette dualité qui nous semble
quelque peu stérile parfois faire
émerger un consensus d'action là où des
visions professionnelles ont tendance à
s'entrechoquer et finalement alors
qu'elles sont toutes nécessaire et
complémentairire alors on fait pas à la
place de on est une petite
administration je vous le disais on est
28 personnes donc évidemment on a aucune
unité opérationnelle qui nous projette
dans le rôle que que tient par exemple
l'office antistupéfiant ou d'autres
administrations on est là pour voilà
avoir ce rôle d'assemblierier
d'innovateur aussi on l'espère
travailler beaucoup sur l'augmentation
de la connaissance par l'impulsion d'un
certain nombre de recherch alors ça
concerne souvent quand on parle de
recherche on pense à la prévention on
pense aux soins mais ça concerne aussi
les questions relatives à l'offre
qu'est-ce que l'on sait précisément
qu'est-ce que l'on peut mobiliser comme
type de connaissance ou comme type de
dynamique pour mieux connaître les
questions dans ce domaine on a
d'ailleurs et c'est assez intéressant
avec l'aide du fond de concours drog sur
lequel je reviendrai dans un instant
constituer une forme de petit consortium
qui s'appelle le programme
interministériel de recherche euh sur la
lutte antidrogue et qui vise à
objectiver un un certain nombre de
phénomènes dont le le terrain a souvent
une intuition si j'ose dire mais ce qui
est important c'est d'essayer de le
documenter davantage et de faire naître
d'ailleurs au sein de notre pays une
communauté de chercheurs sur l'offre en
matière de stup qui n'est pas si
importante que cela en réalité la
communauté l'offre est importante mais
la communauté est est elle-même un peu
un peu limitée encore donc c'est une
partie de de notre travail je disais
l'expérimentation on en reparlera avec
le programme de limitation de la
participation des mineurs au trafic de
stupéfiants ça ça traduit peut-être une
orientation que je dans ce propos
liminaire je souhaite je souhaitais
apporter c'est le le soutien qu'on porte
au niveau local alors en particulier une
partie de notre soutien méthodologique
et financier va directement aux
préfectures qui travaillent avec leurs
partenaires qui sont les agences
régionales de santé les procureurs et
les recteurs je fais un peu simple mais
ce sont pour nous les quatre
institutions de l'État les plus sans
doute les plus au manettes et puis on a
bien entendu les collectivités
territoriales et ça fait assez long ça
fait un certain nombre d'années depuis
2019 que nous que nous adressons chaque
année un appel à projet au maire ou au
président de communauté d'aglot de
communauté de commune pour les mobiliser
sur cette question des conduites
addictives en direction des jeunes mais
c'est aussi dans ce cadre là qu'on a
cherché cette expérimentation tion afin
de limiter la participation des jeunes
au trafic de stupéfiants on mène un
assez gros travail également à
l'international vous savez que sur le on
parle de problème mondial des drogues
donc c'est c'est évident qu'il faut
travailler avec nos partenaires alors
d'abord au niveau européen bien entendu
nous représentons la France au sein du
groupe hor horizontal drogue pardon au
niveau de la Commission européenne on a
fait un certain nombre de travaux dans
ce cadre
lorsque au moment de la période de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne qui se sont intéressés
spécifiquement on avait la main pour
donner les les les les thèmes de travail
à la question notamment de la cocaïne
euh la question également de
l'ubérisation des trafics donc on a on a
pas mal travaillé sur ce sujet avec nos
partenaires européens nous sommes
également évidemment en lien avec
l'agence des nations- Unies unodyc drug
and crimes qui est basé à Vienne qui
chaque année réussi réuni à à Vienne
l'ensemble des des parties prenantes
état ONG euh spécialistes divers sur le
sujet en dehors de ces sessions qui sont
des grands messes assez impressionnantes
on travaille par le biais de financement
qu'on octroit à des projets qui sont
ensuite pilotés par l'ONUDC en
particulier l'un d'entre eux qui
concerne le développement des cultures
alternative face à la culture de cocaïne
en Colombie et en Bolivie avec
d'ailleurs le soutien d'une entreprise
française qui n'est autre que Malongo de
façon à pouvoir faire pousser du café
plutôt que de la coca euh voilà alors au
travers de ces quelques exemples de
notre travail de coordination
naturellement j'en viens sur notre
production de ce début d'année qui avec
des travaux qui avaient commencé 6 mois
plus tôt qui était la production de la
nouvelle stratégie interministérielle de
mobilisation contre les conduites
addictives
2023-2027 qui s'est fait en concertation
et en coopération très éite très étroite
pardon avec l'ensemble des
administrations qui concourent à la
lutte contre les conduites addictives en
général mais les stupéfiants en
particulier donc cette stratégie
interministérielle a été publ validée au
niveau politique et publiée début mars
euh nous avons fait le choix partager y
compris avec avec le cabinet de la
Première ministre d'avoir une stratégie
qui qui porte son nom pour une fois
réellement et qui qui permet de dégager
quelques lignes de force sans rentrer
dans un niveau opérationnel qui se
trouve développé en réalité par
plusieurs autres éléments de
planification le premier d'entre eux qui
a été publié récemment je fais une
petite diversion par rapport à notre
sujet d'aujourd'hui mais c'est le
programme national de lutte contre le
tabac qui a été annoncé par le ministre
de la santé et de la prévention il y a
une dizaine de jours celui qui est en
attente vous le savez c'est le plan de
lutte contre les trafics de stupéfiants
rénovés qui est en cours de non pas
d'élaboration on est plutôt de
finalisation à ce stade également des
feuilles de route que l'on a demandé à
l'ensemble des préfets non seulement de
région et de départements pour embrasser
le champ de notre propre compétence et
travailler à une articulation au niveau
local avec les acteurs que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure pour avoir
une une stratégie au-delà de
l'utilisation par le biais d'appel à
projet de nos de nos
crédits un dernier mot peut-être il nous
revient aussi assez régulièrement de de
de mener des travaux d'expertise sur un
certain nombre de sujets dès lors qu'ils
ont une dimension interministérielle
c'est ainsi qu'on s'est attaché depuis
plusieurs années à trouver des réponses
sur des sujets qui ne sont pas très
simples comme faut-il changer de
statut légal à la à la question du
cannabis faut-il faut-il faire évoluer
le statut légal du cannabis quelle est
aujourd'hui la bonne mesure pour traiter
la question du CBD par exemple on avait
vu l'émergence du crack comme un certain
nombre d'autorités régionales également
il y a quelques années donc on a on a
initié les premiers travaux d'expertise
sur la question du crack par exemple qui
ont été repris ensuite et et tant mieux
dans une dimension plus opérationnelle
par l'ensemble des administration
de niveau régional donc voilà un peu ce
qu'on essaie de faire entre animation de
la politique expertise recherche on le
fait donc avec une équipe qui est
composée de 28 personnes en tout et pour
tout une quinzaine de chargés de mission
qui reflète à peu près les leviers de
l'action publique tel qu'on peut les
imaginer donc le commissaire Salia Bober
représente la police on a également
lieutenant colonel de gendarmerie
inspecteur des douanes magistrat mais
également des gens qui viennent
davantage du monde que je peux
représenter la santé publique
des personnels qui viennent également
nous aider en matière de recherche des
gens qui sont spécialistes des sciences
de l'éducation une conseillère
diplomatique qui porte la voix de la
France dans les instances que je vous
avais que je vous ai énoncé tout à
l'heure nous disposons également d'un
opérateur qui est au service j'allais
dire de l'ensemble des membres du
groupement d'intérêt public que
constitue l'Observatoire français des
drogues et des tendances addictives qui
nous permet d'avoir des photographies
relativement actualisées sur la base
d'enquête pérenne sur la situation
plutôt des consommations et puis nous
avons des des crédits alors d'abord en
matière de au budget général de l'État
le programme 129 nous octroit entre 13
et 14 millions d'euros chaque année pour
l'essentiel ce sont les crédits qui
abondent les préfectures pour travailler
en lien avec ARS rectorat procureur et
nous avons la la charge de la gestion du
fond de concours drogue donc est un
mécanisme que vous connaissez
naturellement saisie confiscation des
avoirs criminels la plupart des somm
transit par la grasque elles nous sont
reversées de façon à ce que à notre tour
nous procédions à un reversement de ces
crédits vers les directions des
ministères qui concourent à la lutte
contre les stupéfiants donc la police
nationale la gendarmerie nationale la
douane les service du ministère de la
Justice et nous conservons 10 % de
l'ensemble de la somme pour mener des
actions de prévention c'est ainsi que
nous finançons notamment le travail des
collectivités
territoriales
peut-être en quelques mots on pourra y
revenir mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
cet argent là quelles sont les demandes
qui qui nous qui nous sont adressées par
les ministères que je viens de citer le
travail la demande porte surtout sur du
matériel pour les forces opérationnelles
des formations de la montée en compéten
des personnels des formations croisées
de l'action internationale et en matière
de coopération internationale nous avons
d'ailleurs étit un peu plus loin que ce
que nous faisions auparavant puisque on
s'était aperçu et c'était un que nous
partagions avec les administrations que
les actions internationales étaient
parfois un peu manquait un peu de
coordination qu'on avait de temps en
temps de l'action en matière de justice
à l'international de temps en temps
l'action en matière de police tout ça
dans des mêmes territoires cibles on a
choisi de davantage coordonner les
demandes qui nous sont faites pour que
il y ait une action conjointe des
services de l'État en direction de tel
ou tel pays par exemple on se coordonne
également sur le financement de grands
équipements c'est ainsi que nous
participons effectivement bénéficiaire
du fond de concours au financement de
deux radars sur la zone antiguyane et
puis c'est grâce aussi au fond de
concours que nous avons tous décidé
conjointement de verser 1 % chacun de
notre de notre part pour justement
travailler à l'augmentation des
connaissances en matière de d'offre de
stupéfiant au travers de ce programme
interministériel de recherche sur la
lutte anti drogue qui est donc géré si
j'ose dire au au sein du F de concours
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir une
dynamique qui est plutôt bonne en
matière de ressources du fond de
concours pour vous donner les chiffres
sur très rapidement mais sur entre 2016
2019 on oscilit entre 12 et 15 millions
d'euros par an qui nous était reversé
par la grâce qu'à redistribuer et
désormais on est plutôt sur un train qui
qui est entre 40 et 50 millions d'euros
par an donc c'est c'est dû à plusieurs
choses d'abord parce que le mécanisme
est mieux maîtrisé à la fois par les
enquêteurs qui saisissent et par les
juridictions qui prononcent la
confiscation y compris jusqu'au greffier
il y a moins de de de difficulté de
problèm de procédure ça c'est vraiment
important je crois qu'il y a un travail
aussi de conviction qui a été fait que
c'est un instrument extrêmement utile
dans la répression la saisie des avoirs
et la confiscation des avoirs criminels
est aujourd'hui jugé comme un des
leviers les plus pertinents pour priver
les trafiquants non seulement de leur de
leur
profit mais surtout
c'est une c'est une atteinte qu'on leur
fait qui qui qui qui est assez assez
douloureuse
vraisemblablement
peut-être un petit panorama de ce qu'on
observe en terme de dynamique à la fois
sur la demande et puis sur l'offre et la
structuration des trafics alors les deux
sujets étant liés hein l'évolution et
l'offre et la demande
évidemment la demande suit ou suscite
même des évolutions en matière de
l'offre d'abord ce donner une bonne
nouvelle alors parfois les gens disent
mais c'est pas possible chez les jeunes
les jeunes quand on regarde les enquêtes
qui sont faites en population
représentative à en classe de 3e ou à
l'âge de 17 ans l'Observatoire français
des drogues et des tendanceces addictif
vous confirmera ces chiffres qui sont
donnés par par par cet observatoire tous
les indicateurs sont à la baisse en
matière de tabac d'alcool de cannabis et
d'autres drogues on a des difficultés ça
a été mentionné lors du pnlt sur la
cigarette électronique et d'autres
comportements et une stratification
sociale aussi qu'on a qu'on aperçoit
très très bien au travers de ces
enquêtes mais grosso modo ça traduit
quand même que en matière de prévention
très primaire très précoce et c'est très
important parce que toutes ces
substances ont un impact sur le cerveau
des plus jeunes on a des savoir-faire
maintenant qui quand même sont sont
assez assez opérants ça c'est le premier
sujet sur le cannabis contrairement à ce
que l'on entend souvent c'est pas non
plus une explosion on a une
stabilisation population générale et on
a même une baisse chez les adultes
jeunes qui est modeste mais parmi en
particulier les plus gros consommateurs
on observe des chiffres qui sont
relativement intéressants c'est vraiment
pas une baisse aussi significative qu'à
17 ans mon inquiétude vient plutôt de la
situation d des drogues dites
psychostimulantes toujours en matière de
demande on
a le produit phare dans ce domaine reste
la cocaïne avec son dérivé le craque
mais n'oublions pas toutes les drogues
dites de synthèse
psychostimulante qui sont derrière et
aujourd'hui on a une appétence d'un
nouveau public pour ce type d'effet
booster soit pour la vie professionnelle
soit pour la vie festive soit pour la
vie sexuelle et on est plus du tout dans
la caricature qu'on avait encore il y a
une dizaine d'années qui était un une
consommation très parisienne dans des
milieux artistico ou autres on est
vraiment désormais sur une utilisation
de ce produit
pour une population beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus habituelle si j'ose dire
et ça c'est inquiétant parce que d'abord
ce sont des produits pour lesquels la
connaissance des risques est encore trop
modeste quelqu'un qui consomme de la
cocaïne a tendance à vous dire j'en
prends que le samedi et je saurais
m'arrêter quand je veux en réalité c'est
pas vrai du tout c'est un produit très
addictif c'est un produit pour lequel on
a pas de traitement très
efficace à la limite les opiacés
l'héroïn on a des traitements
substitution qui font d'ailleurs de de
la France un peu un la la France a une
position de fer de lance dans le domaine
qui explique qu'on a pas beaucoup
d'overdose encore aujourd'hui en France
quand on compare à des pays comme les
États-Unis mais sur la cocaïne et les
psychostimulants en général on manque
réellement de de de de traitement
notamment de traitement
pharmacologique dernier dernier produit
qui qui qui nécessite une vigilance de
tous les instants ce sont les opioïdes
alors traditionnellement en France les
opioïdes les opiacés on consomme de
l'héroïne ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
ce qui se passe au Canada 107000 décès
par an de d'overdose au aux États-Unis
c'est un chiffre complètement
incroyable nous nous demande qu'on soit
très très vigilant sur les opioïdes de
synthèse les type fintanil et autres
alors jusqu'à présent et pour une raison
très simple c'est que on n' pas les
mêmes faiblesses j'allais dire dans le
système du médicament qui a conduit à
l'épidémie sur le continent nord
américain mais désormais comme on passe
sur une production dans des laboratoires
clandestins qui produisent des drogues
chimiques type produit de synthèse il
faut faire très très attention à cela on
a quelques cas qui se sont déclaré sur
un produit qui s'appelle le nitrazem
dans l'île de la Réunion et en Occitanie
ça il faut être très vigilant parce que
c'est extrêmement létal à dose très très
faible et donc ça ça peut entraîner une
surmortalité liée à ce type de produit
produit mais je dirais que globalement
c'est l'illustration vraiment de du
risque massif que font courir
aujourd'hui sur la planète entière les
drogues de synthèse je pense qu'à un
moment pour des questions de territoire
pour cultiver des drogues naturelles
pour des questions d'irrigation pour
tout ce que vous voulez et non et et
surtout parce que le profit est
supérieur lorsque vous faites des
drogues de synthèse il y a vraiment un
enjeu à se concentrer là-dessus ce sont
des des drogues qui circulent très
facilement dans des du fris de poste
et qui sont produites dans différents
pays au cœur même de l'Europe désormais
et qui nous font vraiment craindre que à
l'avenir ce soit un des un
des une des drogues ou une catégorie de
drogue particulièrement disponible si on
regarde maintenant comment le marché si
j'ose dire illicite répond à cette à
cette demande d'abord je crois que bon
vous le savez forcément mais c'est la
disponibilité de tous les produits sur
l'ensemble du territoire territoire
urbain p urbain territoires ruraux euh
un produit phare quand même dans la part
du marché qui reste le cannabis on en a
beaucoup parlé la diffusion donc des
drogues psychostimulantes et en
particulier des drogues de synthèse et
euh des réseaux criminels sur lequel on
observe une forte tension aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que ell cherche à marquer
leur territoire elles ont importé des
méthodes très violentes qui sont liées
au trafic d'armes également qui est
connexe euh prenant modèle ou ou ou
dérivé de de ce qu'on avait plus coutume
de voir de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
en
particulier dans dans dans le monde des
des
cartels l'action aussi des services
répressifs et c'est tant mieux mais on
sait que ça crée de la tension en terme
de marché également
donc aujourd'hui une une violence tout à
fait particulière des réseaux également
qui ne sont plus monoproduits ça je
pense que quand on si vous voulez nous
interroger sur la la question justement
du changement du statut légal du
cannabis c'est une des des illusions qui
serait de dire si on légalise le
cannabis on va porter un coup fatal au
réseau criminel ils sont déjà sur des
tas d'autres produits et et il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui pratiquement de de de
groupes criminels qui s'intéresse
exclusivement à tel ou tel produit un
recours très massif à de l'équipement de
haute voire de très très haute
technologie je crois que le directeur
général de la police vous en a de la
police nationale vous en a pas parler et
puis une évolution des modes de
distribution que j'ai abordé un peu en
philigran de de mon propos à savoir les
points de Deal évidemment persiste et
vont persister très longtemps mais au
côté de cela on voit bien entendu un
essort du Fred postal particulièrement
adapté encore une fois aux droges de
synthèse et puis les call centers avec
livraison qui sont devenus également
importants dans dans dans le paysage de
l'offre
aujourd'hui ce qui a justifié une partie
de notre mobilisation aussi sur le
programme de prévention de la
participation des jeunes au trafic de
stupéfiant c'est le recours de ces
groupes criminels à des petites mains de
plus en plus jeunes souvent 11 ans 12
ans 13 ans plus seulement issu des
quartiers dans lesquels ils habitent
dans lesquels se fait se fait le trafic
pardon mais qui qui sont cherchés grâce
à une sorte de marché national du deal
parfois dans des zones qui sont des
zones rurales distantes de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètr et qui sont
recrutés par les réseaux criminels pour
faire un
travail sur les points de Deal par
exemple voilà un peu ce panorama je je
le résumerai en peut-être en en deux
mots donc à l'échelle française
peut-être une dynamique de l'offre une
structuration des réseaux criminels qui
évolue particulièrement ce recrutement
chez les jeunes ne peut pas être
totalement non plus disconnecté si j'ose
dire pardon de ce mot euh d'un certain
nombre de mots qui traversent la société
et la jeunesse en particulier des
questions qui sont éminemment
d'actualité au travers de question
éducative du sentiment d'impunité forme
d'individualisme de recherche
de de d'argent qu'on va dépenser
immédiatement c'est vraiment très
frappant aujourd'hui quand on regarde
les plus jeunes participants au au
trafic euh et l'extension des réseaux se
fait un peu sur le grâce ou sur le dos
de de de ces plus
jeunes n'oublions pas également toujours
à l'échelle française la question des
atteintes à la probité ou pour le dire
plus simplement la question de la
corruption les annonces récentes du
ministre des comptes publiques en
témoignent à l'échelle internationale
une polarisation plus forte des traités
et des conventions internationales qui
sont moins respectés sans doute
qu'auparavant avec des pays qui tirent
un peu vers eux en fonction d'agenda
politique qui leur appartient mais c'est
ce qu'on a vu au cœur même de l'Europe
avec des initiatives de légalisation du
cannabis qui sont contraires au traités
européens et internationaux et qui se
sont fait voilà à l'initiative de de
pays bon qui aujourd'hui semblent en
revenir pour partie mais il y a des
externalités négatives à tout cela euh
et en arrière-fond de la question du
cannabis désormais sur la question
faut-il légaliser ou pas n'oublions pas
non plus la présence de groupes
industriels assez puissant
qui sont en embuscade pour
éventuellement tirer des profits de ce
de ce sujet voilà et enfin je je
réinsiste une dernière fois avant de
vous laisser la parole pour les
questions sur les sorts des
psychostimulants et des drogues de
synthèse d'une manière générale merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le Président
avant de de donner la parole à notre
rapporteur juste une question sur
l'évolution des des pratiques de
consommation il y a un effet covid ou
pas du tout dans ce que vous avez dit ou
c'est totalement différent alors c'est
c'est compliqué de
de d'analyser en fait quel pourrait être
les l'effet du covid l'effet du covid on
dit qu'il a un un impact sur la
souffrance psychique des personnes donc
on pourrait s'attendre en contre-point à
avoir une augmentation des consommations
alors quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé chez les jeunes on voit plutôt une
diminution sur ces périodesl alors qui
peuvent être d cette diminution
peut-être du également à une limitation
des moments festifs à la sociabilité des
jeunes en groupe donc finalement entre
l'un et l'autre je saurais pas vous dire
de manière univoque quelle est comment
il faut interpréter
ça mais la tendance à la baisse a été
amorcé depuis 2014 et donc est bien
antérieur au covid c'est sur ces 10
dernières années qu'on a une baisse
continue des consommations chez les
jeunes de 17 ans très bien merci de
cette précision Étienne blanc notre
rapporteur très bien merci monsieur le
Président oui de de deux
questions la première quand on examine
les orientations stratégiques de Laam
delka
il est
précisé une réduction de la
disponibilité et l'accessibilité des
produits stupéfiant est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire les mesures précises
qui ont été mises en en place
pour diminuer la disponibilité et
l'accessibilité et puis deuxièmement
deuxème
question comment est-ce que vous jugez
aujourd'hui la coordination des
différents intervenants dans la lutte
contre le le le la lutte contre les les
les
narcotrafic quelle est la place de
l'amid delka est-ce que la coordination
avec les services judiciaires avec les
services de renseignement selon vous est
suffisante et si ça n'est pas le cas
quels sont les moyens pour remédier à à
cette
situation merci monsieur le rapporteur
sur sur la première question
effectivement l'orientation stratégique
qui figure dans la stratégie
interministérielle la manière dont
opérationnellement les choses vont se
passer ça c'est le plan stup rénové qui
est en cours de finalisation qui va nous
donner les action les donc nous nous on
participe à cette discussion qui est
coordonnée par l'ofast aujourd'hui de
façon à apporter des éléments qui nous
semblent importants les arbitrages sont
en cours mais c'est cette feuille de
route là qui constituera la vision
opérationnelle de l'élément stratégique
que vous avez cité sur la question de la
coordination de la action publique en
matière de lutte contre les trafics de
de de
stupéfiants je je je pense
que les efforts qui ont été fait en 2019
pour avec ce plan avec la création de
l'ofast
c'était extrêmement nécessaire et
c'était la bonne voie c'est-à-dire que
arriver à faire travailler ensemble ce
qui ne va pas forcément de soi je je le
sais parce que à la mil d'c on a quand
même un peu un Panau un échantillon de
de l'ensemble de ces de de ces
professionnels et que ce se comprendre
comprendre les cultures professionnelles
des uns et des autres les méthodes les
partager et finalement les rassembler
sur une forme de commandement unique qui
permet de travailler le sujet tous
ensemble je crois que ça c'est la bonne
voie est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
est-ce qu'il faut renforcer ça encore
très probablement par des formations
croisées du partage de compétences du
partage de renseignement qui aille
encore encore un peu plus loin je vais
vous donner peut-être un exemple moi où
je je juge on peut faire encore un un
effort supplémentaire il se trouve que
je reviens de la zone des Antilles il y
a pas très longtemps j'ai été visiter
les préfectures et les
acteurs en Martinique en Guadeloupe et
ainsi qu'à Saint-Martin j'inclus
volontiers dans mon raisonnement la
Guyane parce que c'est une zone qui est
fondamentale pour nous tous j'allais
dire nous tous qu l'on habite sur ces
territoires ou que l'on soit dans
l'hxagone voir que l'on soit citoyen
européen c'est par là que passent
aujourd'hui des flux parmi ceux qui nous
inquiètent le plus ces drogues
psychostimulantes que sont notamment la
cocaïne il est certain que sur des
territoires qui sont comme ça à la
pointe de la lutte qui sont des
territoires qui sont symboliquement
extrêmement importants qui sont des
territoires qui sont en partie en
souffrance d'ailleurs sur d'autres
questions je crois que là il faut qu'on
crante encore un peu plus dans le la
coordination le travail en commun ça
peut s'accompagner le cas échéant de
moyens supplémentaires je pense que à la
fois le budget de l'État le fond de
concours tout tout tout ça devra être
regardé mais je j'insiste un peu sur
cette zone là en particulier pour
illustrer votre
question alors j'ai deux demandes
d'intervention Michel Masset et mariearl
Carlotti et puis Catherine Conconne qui
va rebondir sur ce que vous venez de
dire monsieur le Président Michel très
bien merci donc monsieur dans la même
veine une question aussi vous avez
évoqué à
plusieurs reprises l'activité naissante
sur les territoires ruraux quelque chose
qui est nouveau
apparemment est-ce que ça prend de
l'ampleur de plus en plus
et comment envisagez-vous en fait ou
comment imaginez-vous cette suite sur le
territoire rau notamment où nous avons
effectivement moins de moyens de
contrôle moins de moyens aussi et pour
être issu de ce même territoire vous
dire que ça nous pose un certain nombre
de problèmes je propose qu'on prenne une
série de questions comme ça vous aurez
une une batterie de réponse mariearl
Carlotti ça tombe bien monsieur le
Président parce moi j'en ai trois la
première vous avez dit tout à l' que la
légalisation du cannabis ne portera pas
un cût au réseau criminel ils sont déjà
sur d'autres projets et d'autres
d'autres types de drogue bien sûr mais
est-ce que ça ne protègerait pas c'est
une question que je vous pose davantage
les jeunes et notamment les les clients
et ça les mettrait ça les distancierait
de du de relation avec les petits
trafiquants et les réseaux donc je
m'interroge sur ce point la deuxième
c'est que la la vous avez dit aussi que
la légalisation a été faite par certains
pays européens et qu'ils en reviennent
je comprends très bien ça marche pas
très bien mais la répression à tout
craint non plus alors voilà donc il faut
bien trouver une solution et pas mettre
le problème sous le tapis comme on a
envie de comment on le fait un peu la
plupart du temps puisquon s'affronte
entre ceux qui sont pour la légalisation
ceux qui sont pour la répression mais
dans la réalité on n'arrive jamais à
aborder le problème réellement la
deuxième question elle concerne le le
plan stup rénové dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure moi ce que j'entends de la
lutte contre la drogue aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il faut taxer et cibler les
consommateurs est-ce est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est pas réducteur est-ce
que ça touche aussi les drogues les plus
dures comme la cocaïne est-ce que ça
touche aussi les méthodes diverses
notamment la livraison donc est-ce que
c'est pas aussi un peu uniquement un
slogan je vous prie de m'excuser
d'employer ce terme mais mais qui n'a
qui touche pas le fond du problème ça
montre qu'on s'occupe du sujet c'est
tout et la troisième chose c'est que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure et ça pour
moi c'est fondamental que la saisie des
avoirs criminels est un des léviers les
plus pertinents pour toucher au cœur
ceux qui trafiquent sur quelle piste
voudriez-vous qu'on progresse sur ce
point parce que je pense qu'on a un
petit peu encore des progrès à faire
merci Catherine
Conconne merci beaucoup Jérôme bonjour à
toutes et à tous monsieur le Président
de la mil desk je suis élu sénatrice de
Martinique vous y étiez récemment
malheureusement j'étais ici donc on n'
pas pu se
croiser je viens de ce triangle auquel
vous faites allusion tout à l'heure
guyan Guadeloupe Martini qui hélas un
couloir
un couloir de circulation de la drogue
vers l'Europe avec tout ce que ça
comporte comme conséquence j'ai été élu
ma adjoint pendant 15 ans de la ville
capitale Fort de France en charge de la
prévention de la délinquence et de la
sécurité donc je suis tombée dans le
chaudron de la drogue tout de suite car
90 % de notre délinquence a comme toile
de fond la drogue et ses travers trafic
consommation vous avez dû voir lors de
votre passage le nombre de personnes que
nous avons qui sont atteintes par le
CRAC euh désocialisé dans la rue avec
avec tout ce que ça comporte comme petit
et grand fait de délincen allant jusqu'à
des situations dramatiques à ce jour euh
l'année n'est pas terminée on a déjà 25
morts dont la plupart concerne ces cas
concernent pour la plupart euh la drogue
règlement de compte enfin bref avec
beaucoup de de de drames non élucidés
qui fait de manière expéditive par
parfois des gens qui viennent d'ailleurs
et qui disparaissent une fois leur m
fait accomplis euh je voudrais vous
poser une question est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait des campagnes si elles
existent en tout cas à la hauteur des
enjeux de prévention je je vois une
sorte de
silence ou alors des petites pointes de
temps en temps à l'on de la journée de
la Prévention et cetera mais à la
hauteur du pas à la hauteur à mon avis
du phénomène qui mériterait que l'on
puisse davantage pénétrer les jeunes
publics les collèges les lycées pour
aller leur dire comme il m'arrive de
faire mais je suis un peu comme don
quiichotte face avec les moulins avant à
leur dire que fumer du cannabis quand on
a 14 ans c'est c'est c'est c'est
dramatique ça peut amener à des
pathologies graves qui vont impacter
toute leur vie face à moi j'ai des
sourires je suis pas médecin je suis pas
voilà qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte celle-là
donc je ne sens pas de manière massive
une présence de la prévention qui soit
beaucoup plus préignante et beaucoup
plus massive par rapport au m fait et
une banalisation aujourd'hui fumer un
joint c'est comme fumer une marbau c'est
c'est aussi gentil pas de problème voilà
en tout cas je ne le sens pas alors
est-ce que vous avez prévu après votre
voyage qu'on puisse accentuer cette
prévention et être beaucoup plus présent
auprès en particulier des jeunes publics
oui une première volet de question assez
riche monsieur le Président
Mesdames oui peut-être quelques mots
effectivement sur le diagnostic qu'on
peut porter sur les consommations et les
trafics en milieu rural c'est une
observation qui nous remonte de toutes
part puisque nous avons euh des relais
direct dans les préfectures via les les
directeurs de cabinet mais aussi bien
sûr les forces de sécurité intérieure et
donc en particulier les gendarmes
s'agissant des des zones gendarmerie qui
tous témoignent de ces trafics et de ces
consommations qu'on trouve maintenant
sur tout le territoire français y
compris dans des petits villages ou îes
de taille moyenne qui auparavant étai
beaucoup moins affecté que les les zones
urbaines donc ce sont des témoignages
concordants ce sont généralement sur
l'ensemble du territoire peut prou les
mêmes produits qui sont consommés il
peut y avoir quelques particularités
locales selon qu'on se situe sur des
routes de de enfin sur des flux de
trafic je pense notamment à l'est de la
France on peut avoir des flux qui
remontent vers les les pays belgiques
Pays-Bas et donc on a parfois un peu
plus de consommation d'héroïn parfois un
peu plus de de saisie aussi de de
cannabis à ces endroits-là on a aussi
quelques villes de taille moyenne plus
affecté par les usages de crac que
d'autres qui peut être aussi lié à à des
des trafics enfin très présent dans ces
zones-là donc c'est vrai que le craque
n'est plus du tout un phénomène
uniquement parisien on a pu le voir à
Lançon dans des villes comme alançon à
3 à Compigne enfin on a plein de villes
beaucoup plus petites qui maintenant
nous signalent aussi des usagers de
craque sur la voie publique donc c'est
phénomène qui qui s'est effectivement
diffusé que faire ce sont les mêmes
outils de lutte contre les trafics qu'on
utilise aussi maintenant dans ces
départements plus ruraux que dans les
départements urbains c'est euh donc
lorsqu'on parle des des forces de
sécurité intérieure qui concourt à la
politique de drogue il y a bien sûr la
la police nationale mais la gendarmerie
nationale est extrêmement mobilisée
aussi
et pour aussi contrer ces phénomènes
sachant que les les trafics s'organisent
souvent à partir de quand même de
centres urbains qui ensuite irrigue le
territoire rural aux alentours et draine
là le les consommateurs mais utilis
aussi parfois C territoires ruraux comme
zone de stockage de produits parfois
comme zone de culture on a quand même de
plus en plus d'affaires de
cannabiculture qui sont aussi mises en
évidence par les gendarmes donc c'est un
phénomène effectivement malheureusement
à échelle nationale désormais et on ne
se contente plus de de limiter les les
actions de lutte contre les trafics aux
zones
urbaines merci vous m'avez interrogé
madame la sénatrice sur la finalement la
question du statut légal faut-il le
changer pour le
cannabis moi j'aborde toujours la
question avant de savoir si c'est le bon
instrument c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire ensemble moi je veux faire deux
choses c'est que les gens fument moins
de cannabis en France et que les réseaux
criminels soient moins présents moins
forts et gagnent moins d'argent à partir
de ce moment-là on regarde toute la
palette des actions possibles quand je
regarde ce que constitue aujourd'hui
dans des pays tels que le Canada et les
États-Unis l'expérience de la
légalisation il gagnent sur aucun des
deux tableaux qui pour moi sont sont le
cœur de notre action la la la
légalisation pardon du cannabis
s'accompagne inéluctablement d'une
banalisation du produit et derrière la
balisation ça veut dire une diminution
de la perception des risques et une
augmentation de la consommation en
particulier chez les adultes jeunes les
résultats que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure de manière assez sommaire et
rapide mais montre que dans le domaine
ça fait quelques années qu'on obtient
des résultats pour ces tranches d'âge là
moi je veux pas mettre en risque
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on commence à
tous avoir une conscience que ce produit
est quelque chose de très mauvais pour
le cveau des jeunes et jusqu'à 25 ans et
au-delà il y a même des des des des
données très claires sur l'insertion
professionnelle des adultes sur le sujet
à aller sur un terrain qui va faire
changer la perception peut-être qu'on
est en train un peu de gagner en la
banalisant donc moi ce sujet là je je
sur ce premier point on ne à mon sens on
ne gagne point sur les réseaux criminels
on ne gagne pas non plus ils sont plus
spécialisés là-dedans on va être obligé
de faire quoi de prendre un cannabis à 8
% qu'on va vendre dans des boutiques
dans des bureaux de tabac si on arrive à
les ouvrir parce que regardez les
Allemands ils y arrivent ils y arrivent
pas c'est tellement compliqué en
pratique donc on va mettre un cannabis à
8 10 % si vous penseer que ceux qui
enfin c'est évident que ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les trafics vont
proposer du cannabis à 20 % moins cher
avec des goudises c'est comme ça que ça
va se passer donc on aura finalement
deux circuits ce que voient très bien
les États-Unis aujourd'hui et Canada qui
vont perdurer moi je pense que ça et si
on voulait vraiment éradiquer mais ça je
n'ose pas y penser d'ailleurs pas grand
monde le propose en réalité les les les
les réseaux criminels ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudrait faire des des super stor
officiel de l'ensemble des drogues
c'est-à-dire légaliser aussi la cocaïne
pourquoi pas l'héroïne toutes les gammes
de cannabis moi je pense pas je pense
qu'on peut faire encore mieux plus sans
doute que évidemment on ça va JAMA
jamais assez vite mais honnêtement je
pense que c'est une c'est une solution à
mon sens un peu un peu hasardeuse au
regard des objectifs que je poursuis
encore une fois sur la question madame
la sénatrice de des territoires
Guadeloupe Martinique et puis mettons
effectivement la
Guyane qu'on va voilà mais qu'on va pas
limiter à un triangle uniquement centré
sur les sur les stupéfiants parce qu'il
y a plein de
choses alors la question de la
délinquence liée au au stup oui est-ce
que c'est les chiffres que vous que vous
dites m'interpellent un tout petit peu
moi je au niveau national je reprends ça
mais pour en avoir discuté avec les
autorités locales en matière de condues
addictiv attention à l'alcool tant en
matière d'accident qu'en matière de CRIM
et de
délit oui c'est vrai mais en tout cas
sur l'ensemble du territoire national 30
à 40 % des crimes et délis c'est
l'alcool et en particulier violence
intrafamiliale et je sais que ça existe
également mais vous vous avez raison
donc c'est un phénomène qui
effectivement commence à avoir des
impacts forts dans vos territoires et
que ce que j'appelais de mes vœux comme
un voilà peut-être cranter un peu plus
sur ces territoires là c'est bien sûr
pour protéger l'hexagone et l'Europe
mais c'est d'abord et je l'ai dit pour
protéger les
territoires de de consommations qui sont
qui étai traditionnellement centré sur
en matière de stupéfiant sur le cannabis
on s'est et aujourd'hui qu'effectivement
la cocaïne devient des produits de
consommation en Martinique comme en
Guadeloupe euh alors après est-ce qu'on
a
euh est-ce qu'on est mauvais en matière
de campagne de prévention et de
communication on en fait pas pas
suffisant alors peut-être voilà on n
fait pas on en fait sans doute pas assez
mais je dirais que pour les plus jeunes
que vous avez ciblé au travers de votre
propos c'est c'est un peu ça mais c'est
beaucoup d'autres choses et ça on le
fait plutôt bien j'ai visité notamment
un certain nombre d'écoles alors c'est
moins spectaculaire si j'ose dire parce
que ça se passe un peu plus dans
l'intimité des classes c'est des
établissements c'est pas des campagnes
qui se voient énormément mais c'est tout
ce qu'on appelle le travail sur les
compétences psych-ociales redonner de
l'estime de soi à des gamins qu'on ont
perdu redonner de la confiance en soi
travailler en confiance avec les adultes
respecter l'autorité se respecter
soi-même alors pardonnez-moi mais dans
la littérature internationale c'est ce
qui marche le plus et si on a
aujourd'hui euh une diminution de de de
de des consommations toute substance
confondu dans les plus jeunes âges de la
vie c'est parce que ces programmes ont
été mis en place et ils le sont en
partie insuffisamment vite dans dans ces
territoire là la question des parents
est fondamentale aussi qu'est-ce qu'on
demande moi je pense que les campagnes
d'information de prévention de mise en
avant des risques elles doivent d'abord
s'adresser aux parents moi j'
effectivement on entend des enfants on a
fait un film sur le cannabis avec France
Télévision il y a quelques années j'ta
sidéré il y avait une dame qui disait
moi je préfère que ma fille fume un
joint plutôt qu'une cigarette c'est
c'est ça devient euh ça témoigne quand
même d'une vraie Perre de repère aussi
alors c'est pas bien du tout de fumer
des cigarettes à 14 ans pour la santé j'
j'entends bien mais on voit bien qu'il y
a quand même à apporter là aussi des
éléments aux adultes et y compris
au-delà de la sphère familiale dans le
domaine de l'enseignement dans le
domaine social dans le domaine éducatif
sur des repères assez simples concernant
les les les clés sur les les motifs
d'usage la manière de réagir et puis
surtout apporter des éléments sur la la
dangerosité de certains produits et se
mettre d'accord là-dessus donc là je
suis d'accord avec vous sur ce sujet
mais juste une petite
précision encore une fois travailler à
la confiance en soi et tout je suis
entièrement d'accord et pour moi ça
passe par là mais pour bien fréquenter
la soixantaine d'établissements collège
lycée je peux vous dire qu'on est très
loin de ce qu'on vous a raconté très
très loin mariearl Carlotti oui merci
merci monsieur le Président je vous avez
posé une une question qui pour nous est
très importante pour la suite de nos
travaux vous avez dit la saisie des
avoirs criminels sur quel domaine
comment on peut les faire progresser
d'après vous parce que je pense que
c'est quelque chose vous l'avez dit
extrêmement pertinent pour toucher ces
gens-là quoi
merci je parle sous Valérie ctoyan
complètera mais on a besoin
de de faire en sorte que la procédure
soit très sécurisée en réalité il y a de
temps en temps des des saisies qui se
passent pas bien qui sont alors je vais
pas dire oublié mais insuffisante en
quantité qui les les réflexes qui sont
pas forcément toujours partout dans les
procédures et au niveau de la chaîne de
la justice là encore euh continuer à
convaincre les magistrat les former
davantage pour savoir ce qu'ils peuvent
faire dans le domaine jusqu'où ils
peuvent aller sur pratiquement toutes
les affaires parce que c'est vrai quand
on voit entre si on faisait une règle de
TR je un peu audacieuse mais entre le
chiffre d'affaires global de la lutte
contre les stupes le nombre de personnes
interpellées et finalement les 45
millions qu' l'on récolte on se dit
qu'il y a une perte en ligne voilà donc
il faut qu'on augmente
singulièrement le niveau on va dire
d'information de sécurisation de la
procédure je pense que c'est ça qui est
important et en faire d'une certaine
manière la publicité la grâce qu' a dû
vous parler de la vente qui a été faite
l'an dernier au palais de justice qui a
été un événement important ce qui a été
formidable c'est que tout le monde l'a
compris ça parfois on est attaqué
ensuite dans la presse ou par certains
relais d'opinion pour dire mais c'est
c'est c'est voilà cette mesure est est
finalement écrittipe C pour telle ou
telle raison là il y a une forme
d'unanimité à dire ah on fait ça en
France c'est bien mais je crois qu'il
faut aller plus loin sur à la fois la
sécurisation côté saisie et confiscation
je sais pas si tuas quelque chose vous
pourriez nous donner quelques exemples
de fragilité juridique sur la procédure
de saisie et sur le le le leur
aboutissement est-ce que vous avez
quelques exemples qui vous ont marqué on
a eu al ça date de de quelques années
déjà mais un certain nombre d'avocats
qui attaquai assez facilement le respect
de la procédure not notamment sur la ce
qui se passait au niveau du tribunal les
les les greffiers avaient pas été assez
formés à une époque donc il y avait des
il y avait des points de faiblesse ici
je crois que depuis on y a on a remédié
mais c'était important je sais pas si
vous-même avez d'autres
exemples non c'est vrai que comme nous
on est principalement en bout de chaîne
à recevoir les fonds on a une visibilité
assez réduite sur le process précis de
de saisi des avoirs puis de confiscation
nous on en voit le résultat c'estd une
forte augmentation quand même des des
fonds que nous versent la grâce qu'on en
déduit que tout ce qui est formation des
enquêteurs et des magistrats et du
personnel de la Justice s'est amélioré
mais on on n pas de visibilité un peu je
dire au quotidien des procédures et donc
des points de fragilité je pense que la
la la la progression la plus importante
c'est vraiment que ça devienne quelque
chose de systématique l'OFAS vous l'a
dit mais c'est systématique pour des
enquêteurs de l'OFAS c'est peut-être
moins moins moins moins moins
systématique pour des enquêteurs qui
sont pris dans un flux quotidien plus
traditionnel et que c'est pas uniquement
pour un enquêteur un moyen de preuve
c'est-à-dire que la saisie et
confiscation ça va au-delà du simple
moyen de preuve dans le cadre d'une
enquête deux questions pour ma part euh
la première concerne l'utilisation du
fond de concours drogue euh à la faveur
d'un d'une brève euh j'ai lu que les
licences briefcam là qui étaiit contesté
liciel israélien de reconnaissance
faciale avait été financé par la
hiérarchie policière sur fond de
concours drogue al je sais pas si c'est
exact ou inexact mais plus plus centré
sur notre sujet est-ce que vous avez une
politique d'évaluation de ce qui est
fait euh avec les moyens que vous
attribuez dont vous donz fond concours
drogue ou est-ce que vous vous êtes
juste un bailleur et puis après la
hiérarchie policière gendarmerie sur le
CUP seul ça c'est la première question
et la deuxième vous nous avez parlé du
du d'une réflexion d'une expérientation
un travail de fond sur le rôle des
mineurs dans les trafics est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
peut-être un peu développer pour qu'on
sache ce que vous cherchez o vous en
êtes merci monsieur le Président je
laisserai la la commissaire
divisionnaire Bobet vous parler de de
cette expérimentation peut-être pour
votre votre première question vous vous
redire en comment est-ce qu'on ça on
procède finalement chaque année donc à
en tout début d'année on reçoit cette
euh ces crédits et et le et le volume
global bon c l'année prochaine on va
gérer le le fond de concours 2023 on
sera probablement aux alentours de 47 48
49 millions d'euros la clé de
répartition entre les ministères a été
établie lors d'une réunion
interministérielle assez ancienne elle
n'est pas contestée c'est la police
nationale qui qui qui a 35 % la
gendarmerie à 25 % la justice 20 la
douane 10 et la MDC
10 à partir de là un mécanisme se met en
place où chaque ministère ou chaque
direction interroge ses services plutôt
sur le niveau territorial et les
demandes de financement remontent dans
chaque direction une fois que les
arbitrages sont faits par les directeurs
ils me sont adressés pour vérifier d'une
quelque sorte là le fait que aucun
aucune de serait demande ce qui est
assez rare je vous rassure mais ne
serait orthogonale à la stratégie
interministérielle à la politique que
l'on poursuit tous en commun ça nous
arrive de faire quelques remarques sur
des projet je vous CITIS tout à l'heure
l'exemple notamment de la nécessaire qu'
que les col direction se parle sur
quelques projets internationaux quelques
projets de formation que ça puisse être
fait ensemble plutôt qu'un peu chacun
isolément c'est une des traductions de
de la nécessaire complémentarité
transversalité évidemment sur la
question vous imaginez bien que sur le
listing de matériel qui est reçu par par
nous-mêmes sur la la que nous recevons
on fait confiance au service qui les
demande et à l'arbitrage qui a été fait
par le directeur général de la police ou
de la gendarmerie nationale donc on se
pose pas ce à ce niveau de détail les
questions il y a pas de reconnaissance
faciale comme objectif partagé de
l'ensemble des acteurs que vous
coordonnez sur ces questions de
stupéfiance absolument pas il y a
vraiment nous on fait confiance sur les
les questions techniques ensuite on
évalue on demande à ce que les services
évaluent certains de leurs projets ça
fait l'objet d'ailleurs d'un rapport
qu'on vous qu'on vous remettra on en a
quelques exemplaires ici alors on est à
la frontière entre la véritable
évaluation d'impact qui est assez rare
en réalité et puis plutôt le suivi la
mise en œuvre d'un certain nombre
d'actions voilà c'est pas de
l'évaluation de politique publique au
sens le plus dur du terme d'abord parce
que il faudrait un certain recul sur le
sujet je vais peut-être laisser CIA
Bobet parler de limits alors limit
l'expérimentation qui vise à prévenir la
participation des jeunes au trafic de
stupéfiants on est parti en 2020 du
constat que on a tous partagé ici à
savoir
l'implication croissante et très
préoccupante des plus jeunes en tant que
petite main et un ce qu'on appelle
l'intérimaire du point d' alors 13 14 15
16 ans et que l'idée de de de pouvoir
vraiment intervenir en amont en
prévention primaire en détectant un peu
tous les leviers qui faisaient qu'un
jeune pouvait être amené à vouloir
participer à à ce trafic ça allait plus
au-delà de la simple quête de l'argent
facile mais essayer de comprendre un peu
tous ces leviers et essayer de voir
comment on pouvait agir avec tous ces
leviers l'expérimentation elle a été
pensée avec trois territoires
directement concerné par ces par ces
questions-là pour essayer de voir
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait à la fois
réfléchir euh sur les leviers et les
actions qu'on pouvait mettre en œuvre en
partant de cette approche territoriale
et grâce à les aux acteurs locaux
directement impliqués au quotidien sur
ces questions-là donc on a travaillé
d'abord avec l'OS euh dans le Nord euh à
côté de lî ensuite lîle l'année d'après
a voulu rejoindre aussi
l'expérimentation donc est devenu un
territoire à part entière et enfin on a
travaillé avec Sarcel les leviers qu'on
avait pu identifier on les a travaillé
aussi avec des chercheurs avec des
spécialistes euh alors qui sont loin de
mon domaine qui suis commissaire de
police mais de prévention alors là
encore on a on a vu que les compétences
psychosociales et les programmes de
compétences psych-ociales qui pouvaient
être m mis en place sur le long terme à
l'école auprès des plus jeunes donc CM1
CM2 ou 6e 5e pouvaient être des leviers
intéressants pour à la fois prévenir les
consommations mais à l'origine aussi les
programmes de compétences psychosociales
aux États-Unis c'est de la prévention de
la délinquence comment est-ce que on
faisait aussi que ces que ces programmes
là pouvaient être intéressants en terme
de prévention la délinquence travailler
sur un autre axe qui est celui de la
parentalité euh avec deux aspects à
savoir mobiliser les parents euh alors
clairement on parle des quartiers les
plus touchés par les trafics pour
lesquels l'activité de trafic est
presque conçue comme une activité
quotidienne quand un gamin de 10 12 ans
de ces quartiers voit en montant et en
descendant chez lui des gens qui
participent à C à à ces trafics et euh
faire en sorte que ce ne soit pas conçu
comme une activité banale quotidienne
une activité comme une autre mais une
activité illicite et dangereuse à
plusieurs égards donc l'accompagnement
de la parentalité sur ces sur ces
questionsl parce que le travail qu'on a
fait notamment à Lille avec plusieurs
ateliers alors de mamans qui sont
généralement les plus mobilisés sur ces
questions c'est souvent une certain un
certain sentiment de d'impuissance et et
de manque d'autorité sur leur enfants
donc c'est comment est-ce qu'on
travaille avec eux donc à la fois avec
elle pardon pour partager ses
expériences mais aussi avec des
programmes plus structurés de pré de
d'accompagnement de la parentalité et
donc là on a au-delà des programmes de C
PS le programme psfp par exemple qui a
un programme de soutien et à la
parentalité troème aspect travailler sur
les idées reçues sur les trafics
travailler sur l'idée que ce serait de
l'argent facile rapide que
euh que ça ça n'impacte queux et qu'
sont maîtres de leur destin que c'est
quelque chose qui n'aura pas ni de
conséquence quel ça peut être juste un
passage pour gagner de l'argent donc
travailler sur tous ces leviers là on
déconstruit uisant un peu toutes ces
idées reçues et là on a travaillé sur
des capsules vidéo avec des jeunes de
Sarcel et un réalisateur Sarcellois pour
travailler sur l'impact par exemple que
ça pouvait avoir sur vos parents parce
que c'est un levier qui était
intéressant à travailler avec avec eux
quand on a discuté un peu sur les les
les leviers qui pouvaient avoir de
l'impact sur ces jeunes là c'était pas
tellement vous mettre en danger vous ils
ont une conscience du risque immédiat
mais en revanche l'impact que ça a avoir
sur votre famille sur vos parents sur
vos proches voir une mère qui s'inquiète
ça pouvait être un levier Ress donc on a
tout un une gamme de capsules de vidéo
alors c'est pas magique on met pas les
enfants devant et magiquement ils vont
mais c'est des outils de prévention
notamment à la main des des des
professeurs et des travailleurs sociaux
pour déconstruire un peu et discuter sur
ces mythes là
euh travailler aussi donc vraiment on a
on a essayé là je vous les cite un peu
rapidement mais travailler à la fois
euh avec la justice pour travailler sur
le sentiment d'impunité avec la
reconstitution de procès aussi mettre en
scène toutes ces questionsl travailler
sur la dangerosité parce que on a quand
même même si c'est pas un
levier c'est important de rappeler les
risques et que c'est des risques
judiciaires et des risques d'engrenage
c'estàdire des jeunes qui se retrouvent
en situation où ils pensent qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire un ou deux un petit temps
sur un point de Deal et se retrouve avec
des dettes parce qu'ils se font voler le
produit ou alors on lui donne on leur
donne du produit qu'il consomment sans
penser qu'après ils vont devoir
rembourser l'argent et qui se trouveent
pris dans des engrainages on a pour
rendre un peu ça concret on a quand même
le cas de jeunes qui c'est un procès qui
a été jugé qui avait qui s'était qui
était parti et c'est ce que disait le
président c'estàdire que maintenant
c'est un marché national en CDD à
Marseille 2 mois avec une une offre
d'emploi sur les réseaux sociaux loger
payé simplement ils sont endettés ils
sont fait voler leurs produits ils sont
remontés à Sarcel avec des dettes très
importantes et ils ont été pour
rembourser amenés à conduire et c'est ce
qui a amené au procès à prostituer deux
de leurs amis euh à Sarcel donc on a
quand même des des des des trajectoires
criminelles qui sont commencé par cela
avec
parfois le sentiment que c'est presque
anodin que ça va être ben je vais faire
ça deux trois fois et rares sont ceux
qui se disent j'ai un parcours de vie
dans le deal et que ça va être une une
prpective d'assention sociale mais c'est
des passages qui peuvent être vraiment
difficiles et dernier point travailler
aussi sur de la prévention urbaine et on
l'a vu à l'os notamment avec le travail
avec un bailleur social pour une tour
qui était vraiment le président a visité
cette tour sous sous prot tion policière
l'activation du rid immeuble pour
occuper le territoire quand on quand la
police est intervenue et c'est
nécessaire pour déstabiliser le point de
de et le faire disparaître on agit en
haut du spectre et bas du spectre mais
après il faut proposer autre chose
c'està-dire que cette occupation du
territoire par les habitants par les par
le bailleur et en disant non maintenant
le territoire nous appartient on
s'approprie ce territoire là ça permet
aussi de pas avoir à
remettre du bleu régulièrement mais à
occuper positivement et enfin proposer
des alternatives c'est-à-dire que
montrer que non le D n'est pas une voix
normale mais qu'il y a plein d'autres
métiers qu'on peut faire en venant en
ayant des difficultés parfois donc on a
fait notamment à sarcell des journées
d'ouverture des possibles avec plein de
métiers euh du plus qualifié ou moins
qualifié mais des gens qui avaient
estimé réussir leur vie euh voilà donc
je si vous avez d'autres questions j'ai
déjà non mais je je je complète une
petite seconde c'est juste pour dire que
tout ce que vient de dire euh le
commissaire Bobet a été fait avec la
collectivité la préfecture le procureur
l'éducation nationale l'agence régionale
de santé des associations à voocation de
prévention sanitaire ou
sociale et les bailleurs sociaux et
qu'au final cette fameuse tour de l'OS
pour ne citer cet exemple qu'on appelait
il y a quelques années la tour de la
mort c'est vous dire si c'était quand
même un endroit extrêmement sympathique
quand on y allait on était obligé d'être
protégé on ne pénétrait pas dans les
escaliers de secours tellement ils
étaient encombrés parce que c'est là que
se faisait le deal là aujourd'hui
peut-être un peu grâce à notre programme
bien sûr à cause de l'action des
policiers qui ont débarrassé la tour des
points de dal grâce au bailleur social
qui a revu les logements et grâce aux
habitants qui seraient appropré l'espace
on a l'impression qu'un vrai progrès a
été fait et par ailleurs on essaie de
toucher tous les gosses de la commune
par les actions que que mentionnait
selia Bobet pour essayer de leur montrer
que un un autre avenir est possible
donner aussi des limites tant aux
parents qu'aux enfants et et les
sensibiliser à la à la vie terrible
qu'ils vont vivre parce que ce qu ce qui
est complètement fou aujourd'hui et qui
est une évolution quand même extrêmement
inquiétante c'est au fond tout ça c'est
c'est fun très vite tout de suite et la
se projeter dans un avenir qui peut être
comme ils le disent eux-même dans la
vidéo de Sarcel quatre planches ou
quatre murs c'est pas quelque chose qui
suffit à les arrêter dans ces
trajectoires morbides
on arrive à à l'heure de fin de cette
audition une dernière très rapid très
rapidement monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que vous financiz de
grands équipements je suppose que c'est
à travers le fond de concours et vous
avez parlé de financement de deux radars
c'est quoi ces radars à quoi ils
servaient j'ai pas très bien
compris l'idée c'est de favoriser les
équipements locaux côté anti pour
surveiller des radars de surveillance
maritime ah d'accord
voilà un étonnement pour terminer avant
de vous remercier il y a quelques mois
on a eu une audition à la commission des
lois de la chef de de lofaste et on
lisait on entendait partout stupéfiant
infraction MRE infraction matrice ça pas
c'est une terminologie qui a disparu des
des des radars depuis est-ce que c'est
c'est un choix de est-ce qu'il y a une
coordination autour de l'expression
qu'on a autour de de ce trafic ou pas du
tout c'est une question très ouverte
mais j'avais l'impression qu'il y a une
focalisation sur ce sujet et que c'est
un peu baissé
en ça vous é quelque chose non non ça
c'est pas d'accord d'accord donc c'est
des variations saisonnières dans le
vocabulaire utilisé je pense merci
beaucoup merci infiniment de votre
disponibilité puis on a un questionnaire
écrit qui vous a été adressé on compte
sur les réponsse pour alimenter nos
travaux merci
beaucoup